monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre en août dernier
lors du vote de la loi de finances
rectificative pour 2022 le groupe les
républicains a fait adopter un
amendement il visait à mettre en place
les premiers crédits permettant de
lancer dès l'automne suivant le chantier
de la mise en œuvre d'une carte Vitale
biométrique permettant de s'assurer
s'assurer de l'identité de son détenteur
la vie du gouvernement était à l'époque
un avis de sagesse et vous vous étiez
engagé à prévoir d'autres crédits dans
le plfs plff pardon 2023 l'enjeu est
important
un rapport conjoint de lié l'IGF et de
Ligas à estimer que le nombre de
titulaires d'une carte Vitale excédé de
plus de 7 millions le nombre de
personnes résidant en France
un rapport c'est un rapport sénatorial
quant à lui l'évaluer en 2019 entre deux
et plus de 5 millions
et la directrice de la sécurité sociale
en 2020 reconnaissait lors d'une
audition Parlement un surnom de 2,16
millions de cartes vitales quant au
montant de la fraude sociale il aussi ré
entre 14 et 45 milliards d'euros par an
la fraude à la carte Vitale ayant toute
sa part dans cette dérive madame ce
sujet de la fraude sociale mériterait
que le gouvernement s'en saisisse
vraiment
or que constate-t-on non seulement le
gouvernement n'a rien fait pour aller
dans ce sens mais pire encore aucun
crédit n'est inscrit pour cette action
au plfs 2023
décidément votre gouvernement a bien du
mal à écouter le Parlement apprendre le
chemin de la réforme et à se donner les
moyens et d'économiser l'argent public
j'aurais donc trois questions
ne pensez-vous pas madame la Première
ministre que la lutte contre la fraude
sociale devrait être une priorité et que
tous les moyens pour y contribuer de
votre être mise en oeuvre pourquoi
avez-vous refusé d'inscrire pour 2023
des crédits et donc d'engager enfin le
programme de création des cartes vitales
biométriques et pour finir au-delà de
votre réticence à agir se poser une
question plus large que pensez-vous pas
que dans une démocratie les décisions du
Parlement pardon c'est à dire ce que
prévoit la loi doit être respectée par
le gouvernement